foreign
[Music]
concerns Brazil the only country whose
flag let a little circle where a fancy
sash isn't that nice the circle's all
dressed up for its big day being on the
flag Brazil is one of the largest
democracies in the world with more than
156 million people eligible to vote and
next Sunday it's having a massive
election we've mentioned Brazil's
elections on this show before partly
because campaign ads there can be
spectacular like this one for man
currently running for State Deputy
that's
I'm Samurai taxi driver
you can find me around parenting buco
10554
[Music]
excellent look I don't know anything
about nunchucks I don't know if they are
historically a part of Samurai Taxi
Driver culture and I don't know if using
your armpits so much is usually a part
of it but I will say this I'm impressed
that he spent so much time learning to
use them but seemingly zero time
learning how to edit out the part of the
video where he turns his phone off
many elected positions are on the ballot
in Brazil next Sunday from Governors to
Senators but the key one is the office
of President where Jaya bolsonaro is
running for re-election now you may
remember four years ago we actually
discussed his first presidential run I
assume I don't watch this show but if
you missed it a quick recap bolsonaro is
a right-wing ex-military populist who
when in Congress told a female colleague
I wouldn't rape you you're not worth it
has said I would prefer my son to die in
an accident than to have him be gay and
loves making finger guns all the [ __ ]
time basically bossner campaigned as a
misogynistic homophobe who gestures like
he runs a tech startup but now he's
campaigning as an incumbent president
and he's been drawing on all the perks
of the office including recently turning
the 200th anniversary of Brazilian
Independence into what was essentially a
campaign rally for himself Israel in
Brazil's capital city Brasilia to tens
of thousands of supporters in a military
display wave planes parachutists and
tanks
embalmed heart of Monarch dumpia through
the first who declared Brazil's
independence from Portugal 200 years ago
was brought over from Europe to be a
Slave
Wow first if you were wondering what Don
Pedro the first died of it was probably
his heart looking like that but it's
true they put a two-century-old heart on
an Air Force plane and flew it to Brazil
it is actually the first unnaturally
preserved human body part to fly on a
military jet since all of Tom Cruise
main opponents in this election is
former president Luis inacio Lula de
Silva he was incredibly popular while in
office but later got caught up in the
international corruption investigation
operation Car Wash even Landing in
prison during Brazil's last election so
he couldn't run but his conviction has
since been annulled and polls now
consistently show him leading the race
by a wide margin about 10 percent but
the concerns in Brazil are that if as
seems likely bolsonaro loses he won't
give up his office without a fight and
could even follow Trump's example in
encouraging supporters to back a
tropical version of the capital Riot
which isn't great although for the
record you really don't have to use the
word tropical to describe an
Insurrection just because you're talking
about Latin America especially because
tropical riots sounds like a Mountain
Dew flavor that was recalled for
blinding several children
and bolsonaro's version of January 6th
could be a lot more destructive than
Trump's given that he has done a great
deal to cultivate support within his
military all of which makes it more than
a little concerning when he stands in
front of his supporters and says things
like this
there are only three alternatives for me
to be arrested to be killed or to be
victorious
[Applause]
and I tell those scumbags I will never
go to jail
okay that is never a good omen is it no
one says that before doing something
pleasant no one says their options are
Victory prison or death before they say
March into the Great British Bake Off
tent for biscuit week not even the
German guy and honestly I was half
expecting that from him
the first round of the election is next
Sunday and if no one wins more than 50
of the vote it will go to a second round
on October 30th although worryingly
bolsonaro has already said that if he
doesn't win outright next Sunday
receiving at least 60 percent of the
vote something quote abnormal took place
so if one of the world's biggest
democracies seems like it might be
barreling towards a cliff tonight let's
talk about Jaya bolsonaro the man with
his foot planted firmly on the gas and
let's start with the fact that
unfortunately he's governed pretty much
exactly how he said he was going to he's
followed through on a big campaign
promise to make guns more freely
available in Brazil loosening gun laws
to the point that since he took office
the number of guns in private hands has
doubled to nearly 2 million despite
polls showing the majority of Brazilians
are against making the sale and
possession of weapons easier so he is
giving people something they didn't ask
for and don't want which I believe is
also the job description for the head of
original program at Netflix but much
more than that bolznora has been an
absolute disaster for the Amazon a
rainforest that is critical for Brazil
and you know the planet Earth he has
loosened regulations to expand logging
and Mining there and massively scaled
back protections and enforcement and
almost immediately after he took office
conditions deteriorated under bolsonaro
deforestation is at its highest point in
a decade with an area 10 times the size
of New York City destroyed through
October this year
and in August there was an average of a
thousand fires every day
Amazon a thousand times a day my first
guess would be capybara's [ __ ]
self-explanatory my second would be frog
birthday parties statistically there's
got to be at least five thousand of them
with a birthday every day and we have to
assume that some combined parties for
convenience and others just don't want
to have a big thing this year but
exactly zero of my guesses would be
fires these fires are often part of
illegal deforestation to clear areas for
industrial uses deforestation
incidentally which can encroach on land
where indigenous people live and they
have been forced to confront these
lockers ranchers and miners on their own
which can be both very dangerous and
deeply dispiriting
when we confront them they say don't you
watch the news bolsonaro said that when
he won we could take wood from
indigenous land this is what they say to
us right and it has got to be tough to
fight someone taking your stuff when
they feel they've got permission from
the most powerful person in the country
if I stole your wallet and then played a
clip of Biden saying hey John I don't
give a [ __ ] if TV hosts Rob Their
audience members now if he'll excuse me
I've got to go and say 10 wrong or weird
things in a row on 60 Minutes there
really wouldn't be much that you could
do about it
the point is the destruction of the
Amazon under bolsonaro has been
devastating in fact while worldwide
greenhouse gas emissions plummeted by
almost seven percent in 2020 due to the
pandemic Brazil's emissions actually
grew by nearly 10 percent and boss knows
added insult to injury claiming those
fires in the Amazon were false Flags
accusing Outsiders of being part of a
nefarious plot to seize Brazil's jungles
and directly accusing Leonardo DiCaprio
of funding arson in the Amazon which is
just absurd where would Leo find the
time to do that between his busy film
schedule his daily yacht [ __ ] and having
a big laugh at every tweet about his May
to December love life oh man the
internet got me again Leo shouts are the
richest people on the planet over a
bottle of wine that cost more than your
rent
but perhaps the defining catastrophe of
bolsonaro's presidency has been his
handling of the covid pandemic Brazil
has suffered massively over 34 million
cases and over 685 000 deaths and right
from the start he refused to take it
seriously initially dismissing kovid has
a little flu and then once the death
toll started Rising shrugging off
responsibility in the most dickish
possible way
everything is about the pandemic
nowadays we have got to stop with this
I'm sorry for the dead I'm sorry but
we're all going to die one day everybody
here is going to die we have to stop
being a country of cities wow that is
just monumentally shitty I've got to say
America's coveted response left a lot to
be desired but at least the CDC slogan
was never what are you complaining about
death comes for all of us man up and die
in a hole
but bolsaro didn't just abdicate
responsibility for fighting kovid he
actively made it worse attacking
Governors and anyone else who promoted
shutdowns or social distancing in fact
to the extent that lockdown orders were
issued at all in Brazilian cities they
sometimes came from very surprising
places
the situation has become so serious that
the drug gangs that rule this slum and
other slums in Rio de Janeiro have
decreed a lockdown and they have
forbidden all clandestine parties from
happening it's true drug gangs ended up
being more responsible when it came to
covid than the Brazilian government
although let's not give them too much
credit for Banning parties you know what
is pretty appealing when you're stuck
inside with nothing to do and nowhere to
go drugs
and what is so frustrating here is that
Brazil was better positioned than many
other countries to handle kovit it has a
long history of successful inoculation
drives starring their beloved vaccine
mascot Sega China who at best looks like
a super sperm and at worst a clan member
all dressed up for Jazzercise
and yet bolsonaro not only so doubts
about the vaccines his administration
delayed ordering doses for months in
fact last year Pfizer apparently reached
out to the Brazilian government 81 times
trying to set up a deal to provide doses
of vaccines but most of the time got no
answer and some of those emails from
Pfizer were just sad one read hope all
is well with you I just wanted to
confirm that you received yesterday a
communication sent on behalf of the
president of Pfizer with the updated
proposal of a possible supply of
covid-19 vaccines will you let me know
and come on Pfizer if you're getting
ghosted like that you've just got to be
more blunt something like attention
[ __ ] your country has covered we
have a vaccine let's do this thing or
even Earth to president [ __ ] stop
subtweeting Leonardo Dicaprio and answer
your [ __ ] phone
and the thing is it is not like
Brazilians didn't want vaccines proven
by the fact that once they finally
became available virtually a hundred
percent of the adult populations in Rio
and Sao Paulo got fully vaccinated a
number that no American city has managed
to hit and the cover debacle would be
comfortably enough for people to be done
with bolsonaro but there is so much more
including the fact that despite running
on an anti-corruption platform four
years ago bolsonaro and his inner circle
have since become engulfed in a growing
number of criminal and legislative
investigations while he has denied
wrongdoing one sign of just how touchy
he is about these allegations is that
when a journalist asked him about one of
them he replied I feel like punching you
in your mouth okay
so it is just no wonder that he is
trailing in the polls which is not to
say the bolsonaro does not have his
supporters because he very much does and
they can be intense thousands of
supporters lined up in front of this gym
next to Rio de Janeiro's iconic Maracana
football stadium
inside crowds wearing the colors of the
Brazilian flag cheer for president
calling him the Messiah and the myth
okay I love that man I love his outfits
I love his face paint I love the way he
kind of looks like the Hulk losing his
[ __ ] and the Green Bay Packers game but
what I love most of all is what appears
to be a security guard over his shoulder
scanning the crowd for threats while
looking everywhere but at the bright
green man right in front of him
screaming so hard he might explode
and bolsonaro seems to be deliberately
laying the groundwork with his
supporters for an eventual trump-style
refusal to accept the election results
even pointing to our last election as a
cautionary tale for Brazilians
what happened in the American elections
basically the problem the cause of this
crisis was the lack of trust in the vote
there were people who voted three four
times dead people voted it was a mess
okay great so that is the January 6th
op-ed absolutely no one needed from the
man no one wanted to hear it from and
from the camera angle that absolutely no
one deserves
he's saying his stupid opinions out loud
you really don't have to go hunting for
them right up his nostrils
bolsonaro has been going out of his way
to undermine faith in Brazil's election
system suggesting judges and officials
are trying to sabotage his re-election
and fear-mongering about the country's
electronic voting machines machines
incidentally which are even the subject
of ASMR election PSAs like this one is
don't give up
horny you know every day there are
millions of people experiencing their
own personal sexual Awakenings I'm
guessing that today at least one of them
discovered that softly fondling
Brazilian voting machines is apparently
their thing welcome to the rest of your
life
but Brazil's voting machines aren't just
quietly erotic they're also widely seen
as secure they are not connected to the
internet which makes them all but
impossible to hack and it's worth
knowing that since their introduction in
1996 authorities have never found any
evidence of widespread fraud yet bosnara
has repeatedly attacked the machines as
crooked claiming that his margin of
victory in 2018 actually should have
been even larger he even subjected a
room full of diplomats to a 45-minute
PowerPoint presentation accusing
Brazil's elections of being rigged and
that is incredibly dangerous partly
because people will agree to anything if
you threaten them with a 45-minute
PowerPoint presentation in our office we
have an email security seminar once a
year and this year I broke my laptop
with a hammer just so I could claim that
it did not apply to me it was the right
call and I will do it again
and look I don't want to waste too much
time knocking down every one of
bolsonaro's complaints because it's
pretty clear that in raising these
objections in the run-up to the election
his intention isn't to maximize the
security of the vote but to maximize the
amount of distrust that people have in
it and his supporters have been very
much listening to his [ __ ]
if the elections are fair he wins in the
first round only in the first round he
will only lose the election if there is
fraud and the people will take to the
street to stop that from happening you
see that's interesting isn't it because
if you look at that man you'd think oh
he loves Brazil but if you listen to him
you'd learn he's willing to burn his
country to the ground based on a
flimsley-laid conspiracy theory but I
guess that Duality is just part of the
boundless mystery and contradiction that
makes human beings the absolute [ __ ]
worst
and given bolsonaro's rhetoric it is no
wonder that they've already been
outbreaks of violence one lular
supporter was killed when a Boston or a
supporter invaded his lular themed
birthday party and shot him while
shouting that all PT partisans that is
supporters of Luna's political party
will die so things are very tense right
now in Brazil and that is before you
consider just how close bolsonaro is to
the Armed Forces there not only is he
ex-military and not only has he
expressed admiration for the military
dictatorship that ran the country until
1985. his government is also heavily
stocked with military personnel and some
leaders of Brazil's armed forces have
raised similar doubts to Boston arrows
about the Integrity of the elections all
of which has led some in Brazil to
understandably worry about what lies
ahead
this flirting of president bolsonaro
with the coup is not a recent thing it's
an old thing
the people that support him are willing
to do anything just like the supporters
of President Donald Trump when the
capital was invaded
no I have no doubt I've even written
about it that here in Brazil we will
have a tragic dramatic repetition of
what happened there yeah except
crucially it could be much worse there
because luckily for us Trump's allies
were generally limited to a shirtless
man in a fur hat a perpetually horse
pillow Baron and some of his Dumber
children but bolsonaro has significant
military support and there is some
question of what they might do in the
event of an uprising which raises the
stakes significantly generally when
someone threatens democracy it's a lot
easier to say you and what army when
you're absolutely certain that that
person doesn't have an actual Army
behind them the point is for Brazil
there is a lot on the line here and
right now it seems the most likely
scenario is that no one will win
outright next Sunday meaning that both
bolsonaro and Lula head to a runoff on
October 30th but the weeks ahead could
be extremely nerve-wracking and the fact
is if
eventually loses and chooses to fight
the results it is going to test the
strength of Brazil's relatively young
democracy so to the people there who are
worried right now let me address you in
the two languages that I know you'll
understand Portuguese and of course the
language of the Chuck so please
and you will bear with me
search
that is our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night